what happened when I took a date to
watch me at an improv show ay she
followed me on stage and got a bigger
laugh than I did B she got so drunk
heckled us and the rest of the
performers threw her out C she
accidentally drove her car into the
building and knocked over a lamp
post B that is correct she heckled bro
it was like first of all I didn't think
like she was definitely I felt like she
was out of my league and like I was like
I don't know how I got this girl coming
so she comes to the thing her and her
friend get wasted U my teammates are
kind of like who is this they're already
who's this girl I'm like I don't know I
don't who this girl is and they like hey
you you got to leave you can't be here
like you're talking throughout this like
you can't leave and she looks at me on
stage and she's like are you going to
say something and I was like I don't
know like and yeah was that it you never
talked to her oh yeah she well she
called me and she's like how could you
do I was like you're drunk it's fine
we'll talk in the morning never talked
never talked again